Lush Uno back at it with my partner
player bootleg Kev this is about to be a
crazy One log in with me come on
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here
Lush I was gonna shave because I I
figure if I did it might have been even
more difficult to distinguish us from
one another
this is like the Spider-Man meme in the
flesh okay yeah so first of all
apologize for calling you corny bro my
bad for calling you what I called you I
think you called me a Bam Bam Bigelow
anorexic and I jerk off rappers for a
living I understand manually stimulate
them manually masturbate yeah nice yeah
only a few only a few man
yeah because like honestly I had to get
you it was light-hearted and no and I
saw I saw your comment and you were and
I saw you give me love at the end of the
interview thing yeah yeah like I legit
was rocking with you that's why I kind
of hurt my heart you know what I call it
because I haven't I'd only saw a couple
of things and I think I just hated the
rap part of your guys's little yeah yeah
yeah
it was just it just wasn't great to me
and the red part of our trajectory over
there yeah yeah so how are you doing
obviously it's been about three weeks
now since everything well it's it's been
great wound up securing a caffeine deal
I saw that going going up right now been
doing my own pod going up right now no I
saw you've been doing kind of like um
more like a mentally like a like a
podcast that's more geared towards
because you're obviously how long have
you been sober over three years well
congrats thank you um so the podcast
that you've been doing is it more like
mental health directed so there's like
it's like there's different content that
I'm doing over there one of the podcasts
with uh my boy Kyle is called Rooney
hour and that is geared towards mental
health because we're both sober right um
then I have one called lush world where
I'm doing interviews kind of similar
right you got going on and then I'm
doing streams as well so so the stream
stuff's on caffeine yeah yeah the rats
on that yeah it seemed like he landed on
your feet pretty well man yep shout out
to my boy EK and the A.D also was a
little bit instrumental in helping me
leverage that situation so right I think
like uh for anybody who doesn't know man
I I grew up around everybody in my
family's attics everybody from my dad to
my uncle to my cousins
every single like big male member of my
family was some sort of addict crack
heroin I mean whatever you want to call
it right
um do you remember like uh because I was
I you know the one thing about being
somebody who loves somebody who's an
addict is the most frustrating part is
trying to get them to get clean before
they're ready to get clean it's almost
like you gotta kind of just let them
fall on their face or hit rock bottom
what was your Rock Bottom see it's weird
because my
hitting bottom is essential to getting
sober but for me there is a series of
different bottoms and I would think that
I hit bottom and then and then boom I go
down through the floorboards and then
I'm in the cellar and then boom I go
through the seller and next thing I know
I'm starting to smell sulfur and I'm
approaching the seventh layer of hell
and um yeah what was that what was the
seventh layer of Hail Rock Bottom were
you sucking dick well I never suck no
[__] dick
[__] hell no it was like and then I
realized when I was on my knees about to
blow this trucker for an eight ball of
coke
not just you know pitiful
incomprehensible demoralization
um just lying like being estranged with
my family yeah my friends
um you know I'm I've experienced
anything you pretty much could besides
sucking dick
um you know I've been been shot at been
stabbed been incarcerated overdosed to
crypto times
um had hits on my life so you know yeah
I got one cousin of mine who in and out
of jail his whole life has overdosed
over and over he's been stabbed he's
been shot
I mean this dude it's it's crazy and
it's like then my Uncle Scott shout out
to my Uncle Scott who just got out of
prison for the [__] 98th time he just
messaged me on Facebook I could shout
out Uncle Scott man welcome home Scott
come on he's like I promise you this is
my last time Kevin I hope everything's
all right like bruh
when I was a kid this dude used to come
to my house because he was tweaking so
[__] hard running around with the
Hell's Angels this [__] would be
sitting at my sink picking his [__]
face thinking there was bugs in his
[__] He's tweaking yeah
so I used to go into the bathroom be
[__] blood everywhere then my other
uncle and Aunt
we used to go to their house to play
with my cousins and all the [__]
spoons were burnt yeah it's a [__] up
life man yeah yeah that attic life is
serious and for you like because there's
a few different ways obviously there's
like did you go through AAA or n a
rather well yeah I'm in a 12-step
program but I did go to treatment as
well and um
what when I agreed to go to treatment I
had pretty much gotten to the point
where I felt like I had no more moves
the bust I had already exhausted all my
resources right you know anybody that
was foolish enough to still be close to
me my fiance at the time any of my
friends they were like not [__] with
me and it was either that or pretty much
die I had no other options and I've been
in a lot of treatment centers over the
years the first time I was 16 you know I
went to juvie got arrested for the first
time at 13. um
I the spot that I went to was for
chronic relapsers basically it's like if
you don't get sober here it's a wrap for
you this is the last stop on the train
oh I'm aware and I um I thought that I
qualified as a chronic relapser but then
I realized I've never actually relapsed
because we have a really clean clean I
never made an Earnest attempt at
sobriety in my life so yeah yeah uh one
of my uncles uh my uncle Rocky has a
drug rehab called he he was a huge
heroin addict he's the shoot up right
here damn yeah so he killed all his
veins because he had he didn't want any
anybody to see us he was shoot up in his
[__] eyelids but um this [__]
got clean started a drug rehab and then
when I was like 16 I started working for
him in like a dead and can store but he
had the same type of program called the
hard six program and it was all people
who they were like on their last they
were like habitual relapsers and man so
I was like 15 16 working in a [__] a
can store just with a bunch of [__]
recovering dope fiends yeah then I
turned 18 and I got a job running his
Consignment Car Lot literally every
employee was a [__] freshly recovered
drug addict so I was babysitting dope
fiends at 18 years old and that man
Crazy Life shout out to everybody who's
who's staying clean so for you was it
like because I always hear like there's
because you know nowadays especially
being in Cali there's like weed there's
there's psychedelics there's California
silver correct right yeah so for you
You're Sober Sober yeah I can't [__]
with none of that [__] so if you smoke
weed you feel like it can kind of be a
Gateway I don't want to attempt fate you
know like I'm still high I've done
smoking so much weed in my past right so
to the point where like I have no like I
have no desire to even try it again you
know who knows in the future I just know
for right now for today I'm not [__]
with it yeah just um there was somebody
I just saw in Joe Rogan they're they're
clean and sober but they were like
considering
trying I think Ayahuasca yeah see like
you know I've already had them
psychedelic you've already had a
hardcore experiences there's no real if
I would do that for me that would be a
relapse because I just want to get high
I just want to get outside my body but
that's nothing that I can attain with um
you know prayer meditation I can do all
that and and reach that same level of
Consciousness that's where I don't need
where a lot of the uh your friends
family I know I saw some of the fans
were maybe a little worried that with
the situation that just happened at no
jumper that you your sobriety might have
been uh in question or or you might have
maybe gotten mentally hit by it did it
bother you in that way were you able to
kind of get through it the I was able to
get through it by the grace of God
however I will say the closest I've
gotten to relapsing the only time I was
like considering it really considering
it was after Adam kicked me out that day
and I I was driving around the valley
you feel me like driving around the
valley not stopping because I knew that
if I stopped I was going to go to a
liquor store and get on and get along
get me a little bottle and get it that
day that day what was it that made you
what did you call do you have a sponsor
I do have a sponsor and I call my
sponsor and like that was between him
that's dope and people that are close to
me they want to talk to me off the ledge
and I realized nah that's not how I want
to move but yeah no it was really it got
dark yeah dude I mean I can only imagine
because I I do see like uh even just
being on the show the day because I I
got hit up the day um that all that
happened we were at at lunch
and uh because y'all film the next day
right yeah the next morning yeah and uh
we're at lunch and Adam just hit me he's
like hey this is what happened you're
down to be a guest on the show tomorrow
just I just need to fill in I was like
yeah whatever I've been on the show
before I was like cool I got you bro
like Adam's always been super stand up
with me you know and uh
but then I really like didn't really
really realize like oh 80's about
because 80 called me and 80 talked and
he was like dude I'm about to quit right
and I was like Jesus Christ like what am
I walking into and then everyone assumed
I'm like the permanent new guy on the
show right so well you had a dude that
is kind of like a New York version of
A.D correct you had like a lush one of
Jason's character correct it's like oh
look yeah you're white yeah okay he was
like oh look there's a white guy with a
fitted baseball right right yeah so I
think um it was I just and then I didn't
know about the Reddit thing and then I
went on Reddit and I was like oh
this is wild yeah it gets deep do you
regret diving into that part of it not
even for the result of what ended up
happening but just I do feel like I
could see how
going and looking in that toxic ass
thing and seeing everyone's opinion and
just kind of seeing all the negative
[__] that gets set in there could
probably like subconsciously [__] with
you well here's the thing
yes is the short answer however
right before I wound up because you know
first me and disaster had the our own
podcast on no jumper oh no I remember
that yeah and it was cool and we were
just focusing on battle rap and just
Lyricist which is like the lane that I'm
in right another reason why you and I
are kind of similar we're both hardcore
hip-hop Romantics you feel me like and
um then they wound up bringing me on the
the main podcast on the no jumper show
and then people really took to me and I
wound up becoming a staple over there
and just one of them like at one point
in time I feel like anytime I'd like to
see a thumbnail you were on it I was
like yeah absolutely within the past six
months yeah I was on that channel more
than anybody else right 100 so what
happened was right before I wound up
being brought on to the other podcasts I
would I'd hit a low in my life and was
very depressed going through a lot of
changes and um it was just like down you
know my my chicken eyes split up right
my mom was terminally diagnosed with
terminal illness you know my company was
going through a lot of changes my battle
rap league so I just felt like really
unstable and you know I was like damn
you're suicidal I was suicide this is
prior to you and disaster doing this is
not this is or after after disaster and
I and before I got before you became
like a normal right right a regular so I
was super depressed I wound up going on
the show when I'm on there I'm like
they're probably not gonna [__] with me
like the crap the audience don't you
know I'm I'm older I'm not really in the
same vein is a lot of different people
they're probably not going to [__] with
me but then all of the comments were
like overwhelmingly positive right and
people start bombarding my Instagram and
like telling me to go to the Reddit and
all that and at that point I was so
depressed the only thing that was really
keeping me going was going and seeing
the positivity you were getting right
right at that time yeah yeah the Reddit
the YouTube comments the social media so
that really it wasn't for that I don't
know if I would have made it through
that dark period so I I'm grateful to
the Reddit for that right however I had
to I should have separated myself at a
certain point but it becomes you know my
addict's mentality it's literally like
chasing me I can see how that [__] is
addictive this validation is you know
sure for for an addict and even just the
even because you're a part of it and you
just want to probably just be like what
are these [__] saying about
right A B C or D look everybody over
there checked the Reddit whether they
want to admit it or not they like some
more than others but everybody is is
peeping the Reddit to some extent not
like I was I was actively posting on
there and then at a certain point when
the when these people in the Reddit saw
that I was going in there like oh they
start messaging you well we could get a
reaction out of him so then like and
then when the when the pendulum
inevitably swings to the other side from
that love to them not [__] with me
and dissecting me and you know what I
mean that right there I was trying
trying to win them over and it became
like this right vicious cycle yeah I can
only imagine man because like you know I
got a family I got kids and [__] I'm
like bro I would never want to be uh I
mean I feel like the type of [__] I do I
I purposely don't touch certain [__]
because I don't want to
like over expose myself I guess and my
kids and my girl and [__] so I even told
Adam when all this shit's been going on
the last few weeks I was like bro you
got some [__] thick skin brother
because
this [__] is crazy they would have been
on your ass if you had gone over there
permanently yeah but even just like just
seeing like you know because I know Adam
I could um
addressed whatever allegations over and
over so I'm like yo this [__] got
brought back up and I'm like bro here's
here's the thing and I want your opinion
on this yeah I genuinely believe that if
Adam had not gone on that pod right when
I was on there and fired me in the very
unceremonious manner in which he did
a lot of that [__] wouldn't have
happened I agree and I think I might
have said something to that effect on
the podcast I think you might have yeah
I did I I did I did say something like
that I was like because because I do
think that that moment was so viral
and it also highlighted
whatever
said issues that and I even told Adidas
when he was on here I was like you were
planning on leaving because there ain't
no way thick skinned ass like A.D I know
got so mad about someone saying he has
four jokes that he quit like he was
planning this [__] you know but but
here's the thing A.D for show was and
I've been telling him he should leave I
told him and Tyrrell like you guys
should be the [__] La drink Champs
and they and they got their own thing
going it's going really well for them
here's the thing
it kind of forced a.d's hand it did with
it being published and when it was also
a nice opportunity if you were planning
on leaving already and those Wheels
already in motion it was a nice
opportunity to kind of take advantage of
the of the you know the virality of the
moment and I think it was Mutual I think
that Adam and no jumper was wanting to
Pivot away from that considering they
are at a certain point is a conflict of
interest when there's other podcasts
with I don't want to say regurgitating
but utilizing right the same content
that you are and getting more abuse for
it I'd assume he probably regrets firing
you at the time and like not to say that
he shouldn't have fired me but he could
have easily taken me outside no I think
and I think he he explained it to me
like if you catch some girl cheating on
you and she's at work and you're in the
Next Room if you caught your girl
cheating on you you're gonna be so
[__] pissed you're [__] going in
then you're [__] up her job like and
I was like I get it if like you guys had
that relationship and he truly felt like
what the [__] like
it was short-sighted and that is why
people should not ever make certain
decisions when they're emotional because
you always regret those decisions 100
but I do think that had he handled it a
little bit and I'm sure he admit would
admit the same thing but here's the
thing like to an extent
I and that's what I was kind of going
back and forth in my head was were he
just so mad and I know that was an
element but I honestly think that's
capped to an extent it might be because
there was a moment and the reason why I
think that he that he thought that he
was gonna dunk on me you feel me and
everybody was just gonna be like oh damn
Adam just [__] marked Lush out right
damn Lush is such a snake [__] him right
and they were gonna be like yeah Adam
you're the man you look so cool because
if if he if this is something he
regretted then why did he post it not
only on the no collab post that's the
one thing the collab post is crazy I
think I said that at lunch because
because I think he said my boy uh ours
has showed me and I was like oh he
collaposed this so not only the no
jumper fans are gonna see it but his
fans now has gotten millions of views
95 of the comments are on his helmet
like this is a dude that has stated
several times and this isn't a disc to
Adam at all right because I you know
ultimately all this aside I do respect
him you know he said
everything is content
everything is fair game you know so I
believe he's like [__] it like oh firing
Lush that's one thing let's fire Lush on
on the air and then it wound up you know
kind of having an adverse effect that he
hadn't anticipated for you as
short-lived because what you would would
you say you were a regular oh no jumper
from September okay so about seven or
six months yeah six seven months yeah
for you even though it ended the way it
ended even though there might be bad
blood now
it did change your life absolutely and
it kind of puts you in a position to
kind of explore a new career path or A
New Path of life because you've always
kind of been a personality yeah yeah but
now you can go and do caffeine and I'm
sure like not without no jumper those
things probably don't present themselves
correct and who knows the trajectory of
Life something else could have popped up
you know what I mean like but absolutely
so I'm very I'm grateful for what
happened like as far as me you know no
jumpers and platform that I've Loved for
years um yeah I'm grateful for my boy
disaster for presenting that opportunity
to me and making that happen and if it
wasn't for that yeah my I wouldn't be
doing what I'm doing now I wouldn't you
know my fan base tripled since I went
over there so
um it's dope yeah yeah you know but like
kind of like you said though like
certain things that were brought about
in that conversation in the moment where
he was um firing me were things that
weren't even discussed which wound up
biting him in the ass further because
there was no conversation about salaries
although yeah it was Ice
just kind of stirred up all these others
right was our six figures up yes but
like that was never something I
discussed with those people in the
Discord and then like Tyrell and these
other people were like yo well hold up
yeah wise buddy over here getting paid
this and I'm getting paid that and I'm
supposed to be the star over here like
it just created it sold a lot of seeds
of discontent were you making more than
everybody over there I was one of the as
the personality I was one of the higher
paid people was it like what you and A.D
probably yeah probably something like
that I don't know what everyone gets
paid you were also there though I mean
to be fair while T Rail and AD were
probably the quote-unquote stars of no
jumper you probably were there more yeah
yeah yeah I I was how many days a week
four or five days a week yeah but the
thing is this what happened was
due to the like when 80s was when 80
started community and t-rail started
back on fig there was no precedence that
Adam had no idea that those that was
going to take off the way there was no
president before them to be like I
should put these guys under contract
right yeah and even like look I I
approached Adam towards the end of last
year kind of having an awareness about
that I was like yo I want to start doing
my own streaming and podcasting like I
want to offer you guys a percentage of
the revenue of whatever I do you know
what I mean because if it wasn't it
wasn't for y'all I wouldn't be in this
position and then there Adam was like
taking it back and he was like whoa I've
never even considered that but like
we'll talk about it and get back to you
instead what they wound up doing is
presenting me with the contract which
was exclusive exclusivity where they
didn't want me to do anything else
besides no jumpers yeah which apparently
is now like the president of their
setting with everybody that they're you
know well they just fired a bunch of
people yeah I mean now was all [__]
different you know I was gonna say
because I even I was there a few weeks
ago and I feel like I just saw that
video I think you posted it it was a
crazy video I was like damn all those
people are gone yeah like there's other
people that weren't even in the video
that are gone too so is it like just
Josh now I mean they have people that
they've brought over in the past couple
months I like well actually like I love
Flacco still over there uh Almighty
suspects still over there court and uh
and um I'm uh an icon and those are the
only on on-air personalities left
it's bootleg cab here gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
friends at King Palm now listen guys all
I do is smoke out of King Palm if you
see me smoking it's out of King Palm all
right and I'm gonna shout them out
because it's all natural
no tobacco it's a tobacco-free uh
product also no additives no need to
split it open no need to lick it comes
ready to go all you have to do
is put your uh your tree your flower of
choice right into here and you're good
to go now the best thing about King Palm
they have these turbine enough infused
wraps right here they're flavored uh
this is my favorite I do love watermelon
all right bursts of watermelon flavor
again no tobacco no additives all
natural all you got to do is pack it and
you aren't ready to go now this is
what's dope about King Palm if you go to
the website right now you know they're
the new sponsor I've been using them
forever so I had to hit them up like hey
guys I'm tired of smoking you guys a
[__] I'd love some support on the
podcast of course all right so go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg Kev and You're Gonna Save 50 off
um you can get whatever you need you can
order it online because these are
tobacco free no nicotine baby all right
so you can get it right to your house
half off kingpom.com keyword bootleg
heavy you could also hit your local
7-Eleven you could also hit your local
smoke shop one of the best-selling
brands in America at the smoke shop so
many different products rollable wraps
hemp cones all the smoking accessories
one would ever need the smoothest smoke
the easiest to use
what are you [__] doing if you're
smoking and you're smoking at anything
but this you're [__] crazy all right
go check them out online socials one
more time kingpom.com promo code bootleg
save half off taking you on that natural
path King pong baby hey also shout out
to the homies at Blue chew man don't
forget if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather bluetooth's where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra anacialis but it's
in a chewable form all right it is sent
right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a Bluetooth use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free also got a shout out to my bookie
man Final Four Is On The Way NBA
playoffs are here well almost here we
got like a few games left right so much
going on you got the Masters coming up
man so many ways to win money
join us in my bookie I've been using my
bookie for about a decade now it's where
I put all my bets in uh there's so many
ways to win money with my bookie if you
go to my bookie right now you sign up
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg and you
will get
double deposit bonus action that means
your very first deposit up to a thousand
dollars make that deposit with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up for
that new account and they're gonna give
you uh uh another thousand dollars
they're gonna double your first deposit
so you might put 200 in you might put
500 in they will give you another 200
another 500 to gamble with all right so
much to do with my bookie obviously we
love betting on sports literally one of
my biggest passions in life is gambling
away my money and winning money on
mybookie.ag now I got a few Futures
going on right now I got Joelle EMB
doing the MVP I got the Phoenix Suns to
win the West I got the Bucks to win the
East NCAA action I'm taking UConn all
the way what are y'all doing go to my
bookie right now they got the props you
can do the player props you can do the
over unders you can do whatever you need
plus live Blackjack live roulette I have
so much fun on my bookie you really
don't ever need to leave your house
shout out to my booking mybookie.ag sign
up right now with the promo code bootleg
and get that first deposit bonus
what are we talking about who else is
going to double your first deposit
ladies and gentlemen mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg sign up and let's win some
money now let's get back to the
interview so for you what is something
that because you kind of were in the
middle of the peak of the dysfunction in
terms of just like if we were to think
about like the on camera drama and no
jumper you were pretty much there for
all the all the hits all the greatest
hits a lot of them so for you like is
there anything that you regret from that
era or oh absolutely like what
absolutely but now now to be fair a lot
of that [__] started before I was even
in the mix right and then you have
nothing to do with the house phone thing
yeah yeah no and then there was because
prior to me being even like
a prominent character over there
there is T Rail and um there's the the
t-rell and uh Almighty suspect there's
like a lot of different things right
but
what I really regret because I feel like
going into January
we're on a very harmonious level
everybody was getting along we're all
[__] with each other we had that CR
you know that that video I posted
earlier was from the Christmas party
everybody's like we're one big happy
family right and then in the beginning
of January I wound up you know Adam told
you about it how he like encouraged me
to get at Flaco and [__] I regret I
should have never done that because that
completely violates my moral compass as
is a man in recovery like now I get
making fun of people is one thing joking
around we all can who ride each other
but I think that I took it way too far
and a lot and was did something that I
knew was wrong even though I was asked
to do it by my boss who I was trying to
you know who I wanted to be happy with
me but at the same time it wound up
setting in motion Not only was it wrong
to [__] oh I'm cool with now right but
to set an emotion a chain of events
which kind of led to what we're at right
now crazy a lot of people are saying
that you might be suing
I mean if I was I wouldn't talk about
that anyway right that's fair I was
gonna say because like I think like
there's a few ways to look at the whole
situation it's like if you Sue it's like
I mean I don't know if that bridge is
ever going to be unburned but it kind of
really burns the bridge absolutely I
mean I feel like there's no Bridge
there's no the bridge is over the bridge
is over the bridge is open yeah yeah
just South Bronx right here can you feel
me
um for people who don't know like kind
of give me your uh uh like roots in
terms of hip-hop and like getting
involved in the battle scene
um you know I've been involved in
hip-hop culture my whole life right um I
started started rapping when I was 15 in
the mid 90s
um used to go to Project load and things
like that and just like you know
elements was that on Tuesday night or
Thursday Thursday night yeah
I was too much of a kid but I always
heard about it yeah yeah yeah and I was
like you know I'm just soaking up the
game and soaking up culture moved uh
born and raised in Los Angeles moved to
the Bay Area to Oakland California when
I was 19 and that's really when my um
you know in career as a battle rapper
started I started off as a battle rapper
got a lot of Buzz locally and then it
started to grow bigger I was in a
popular uh local group called Delmon
crew at the time where we were pretty
much in Oakland in Oakland anytime there
would be what year was this this is like
uh from 2003 to you know that's like
yeah straight right Fiera yeah yeah yeah
so we were I was there for the whole
entire hyping movement and kind of like
what we were as a crew shout out to my
brothers Plex Rock and Ajax um we were
like kind of anti-ant no no no no no
like we were like like if you saw the
way we dressed and [__] you would think
we were just regular hyphy rappers but
we were super lyrical and like we would
do like boom bap tracks and then we
would do like hyphy turn up [__] like
too like we had music with Mr Fab and
all that and we had music with Jairo and
you know um Sean Price were the first
group from Oakland to do a song with
R.I.P Sean yeah shout out to Sean P man
so yeah and that was like a whole thing
and then it wound up uh the battle rap
thing started popping off and um at a
certain point
in 2008 uh I linked up with this company
called Grind Time which was like the
first prominent battle rap fixture on
YouTube and I got to the point where and
they started in Florida me being from
the West Coast it was like look I know I
got some Talent as an MZ but I'm way
better as like a curator of culture and
organizer and a host and like just like
kind of you know what I mean so I wound
up and it wasn't even like that I was I
won't say that that was the most
organized of any of my friends but I was
at least disorganized so you were trying
to so essentially you got brought on to
grind time to help bring events together
yeah yeah and I wound the brand of the
West Coast yeah and this is right when
World Star Hip-Hop was popping off we
were on the front page of Worldstar
every drop that we had Wanda blowing up
you know I remember that yeah people
like disaster dumbfounded no can do like
all you know a lot of the the great
lyricists of the West Coast and then um
daylight like and then I also brought a
lot of the top east coast rappers and
Midwest and south rappers to Cali to
battle for the first time Arsenal
conceded
um
T-Rex Calico like a lot of these dudes
got their a verb had their first first
time hopping on a plane was through me
booking them out west the last I think
the last big battle I ever went to was
in Phoenix and it was when daylight took
a [__] on stool in the desert yep yeah
yeah were you there
no or disasters here for people though
yeah yeah no no no
um but that was a seminal moment was it
I mean just for the [__] I just think
of like the viral moments that I
remember recently it was like that it
was like cannabis pulling out of [__]
I was a part of that yeah yeah he was
there for that and then even him
battling Cassidy I remember that which
and and those are both battles that I
curated as well so so in your in terms
of like your role in the battle rap
world you're kind of like I wouldn't
like maybe an executive or look to us
yeah
I'm like a West Coast smack you know
what I mean like yeah West Coast smack
shout out to smack I've made a lot of
money selling those DVDs well they're
smack white I'm white smack you feel me
like as long as we're not doing smack
fellas yeah yeah as long as I stop doing
smack what was your was that your uh no
no no I was across the board I was doing
everything real garbage can head
honestly Kev I believe the reason why
I'm still alive and able to talk to you
right now is because I would kind of
like
substitute addictions for one another I
would go on like have like little runs
yeah this week I'm gonna crack next week
right I would have like a five month
Coke binge where I'm just doing coke
every day right then when it was getting
too gnarly like I would substitute it
with ecstasy and then I'd do Ecstasy for
a couple months every day you ever blow
some cocaine up a chick's [__] hell
yeah wow snorted coke up a [__] yeah
bro yeah I just in in uh what's that
show called
with [__] Uncle Jerome and and
Franklin saying goddamn snowfall oh yeah
yeah first episode the FBI agent's like
blowing Coke up with chick's ass and she
dies yeah no I've never I've never
yeah
true that is cocaine sex cocaine sex is
amazing but don't you have to also have
a Viagra you have to have your dick hard
yeah because I heard Coke tits I've
never done anything so so for me being
on coke being on Blow I much prefer to
just get my dick sucked just like
because I it might oscillate from being
hard and soft but and then you can and
then you can you know you feel me if you
want to get your dick hard go to
um
royaltyhoneyusa.com I see you just got
that discount code Lush Uno all
capitalized l-u-s-h-u-n and while you're
at it I have to take this moment to say
we are a very proud partner with
Bluetooth oh come on let's go to.com and
get that [__] hard use the promo code
bootleg I will trade you some honey
packs for some Bluetooth yeah good deal
buddy done deal done deal
shout out to the honey pack some of them
taste really good some of them are
god-awful yeah yeah these ones you know
is it an Asian company it feels like an
Asian company I'm not saying it is it
just feels like it this one is a
latino-owned coconut yeah yeah but um
I'm not sure the origins of all the
components yeah I I was because I've
only done uh weed in in um shrooms the
the honey all my family scared me from
drugs the honey Packs work and I and and
you know I talked to my sponsor before I
indulge it is not considered a relapse
so you can do a honey pack I can do a
honey pack I love it so back in the day
[__] like I was 20 years what's the
best drug for sex ecstasy hands down
again you have to be mindful of the
erection issue you know what I mean so
ecstasy you might have a it it's
possible it is if you ever do a Viagra
an exercise I never tried Viagra before
really but yeah like or a Buchi rather
or a Bluetooth rather or a honey pack
however
um what I
like a lot of people like really like
Percocets for sex and I've heard that
thing because it does it make it numbs
indulge your senses to the point where
you could just you're gonna last a long
time
I've done the perk dick done any dick
but yeah for me ecstasy and the the
biggest thing yeah pause the biggest
um thing that I miss from drugs of
anything is like the drug and sex
combination and because it elevates your
sex a little bit it did and I had to
learn like I'm so used to being [__]
up since I was 12 years old 13 years old
the 12 actually is when I first started
getting high to the point where I had to
relearn how to do everything sober
normally yeah yeah yeah like you gotta
kind of almost retrain your body yeah
your brain
dependent learning hashtag that to the
point where I literally you know like
having a conversation you know uh doing
something like throwing a ball you know
what I mean like um
you just have to relearn how to do
everything music yeah having sex like I
was super nervous the first time I had
sex and sobriety because I was like what
okay because I I always
for whatever reason crack seems to be
the drug most straight men will suck
dick for is if if you were to tell me
which drug feels the best when you first
try it because I always feel like it's
got to be cracker heroin yeah I mean
because you always
like
the thing well here's the thing the
crack is like same [__] it's like doing
opiates like in order to get to heroin
like if you if a regular person or even
someone of you just sip lean a few times
or this or that right and you went to
heroin you'd be sick you'd be throwing
up it wouldn't feel good so if you go
straight to the black tar you're [__]
can't you can't you got to work your way
up to that
crack when you first you know the first
time you smell crack you um yeah it's
lit to me yeah but but I would say like
in honestly
psychedelics like to me felt the best of
my first time I shroomed out right yeah
like I love that I love psychedelics for
sure yeah I've never tried crack I don't
plan on it don't do it I won't I won't
don't worry
I gotta stay away man my whole family is
on that [__] so you know you can live
vicariously through my past but yeah uh
crystal meth was another one that felt
really good when I first tried it and my
baby mama was a meth head shout out to
her that's a big thing is she from
Arizona too that's a big thing in AZ the
first couple rehabs I went to were in AZ
Wickenburg did you go to work yes I did
go to The Meadows yeah a couple times I
was in Wickenburg and uh I was in
another spot called the Prescott House
Prescott yeah yeah in Prescott Arizona
yeah you say it the right way the right
way you said the right way because yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they made it clear
like don't say Prescott [__] you no you
won't Prescott yeah plus a bunch of old
[__] up there no that's a [__] up
town bro like yeah shout out to press
let's get in Prescott Valley Prescott PV
is gnarly full but yeah
so for you
um what are the the lessons that you
kind of learned from the last year or so
that you're going to try to apply to
your own content and what are the good
things that you've learned too because
you I mean obviously Adam's built a
Powerhouse you know yeah absolutely like
I've learned a lot about I've learned
the whole craft of podcasting and I'm
sure you can attest to this it's not as
easy right as it looks like you have to
like being able to conversate with you
like I can tell like you know what
you're doing right you know how to
podcast there's a whole skill set that
goes into it you have to kind of know
how to steer a conversation when it's
getting redundant what's going to be
interesting
um how not to repeat yourself I don't
have to say um um like like like a
hundred times there's a whole and so I
learned the entire craft of podcasting
and I'm fairly decent at it at this
point so I'm grateful for that so you're
going to be how many days a week are you
going to be doing content I'm going to
be doing content three days a week nice
so um but I'm going to be focusing
focusing on it a lot more but really my
primary focus all that aside my brother
disaster and I we have our battle rap
League GTX which is the continuation of
grind time and that's been um that's
what I was doing before the whole
podcasting thing took off and you know
like this is my passion and my roots are
in the battle rap culture and I'm it's
an honor to be back we got our first
event of the year called the lot in a
few North Hollywood in North Hollywood
yeah who's babbling we got disaster for
us next we got Denny Myers versus Deb
the demon we got active versus real name
Brandon and a Litany of other fire ass
battles vote that ass what is the
business model of the battle League
thing are you guys making money off of
pay-per-views you guys I mean obviously
you're making hard ticket money I'm sure
but like I know a lot of these guys they
demand a a purse yeah right yeah you
gotta figure I'd always uh was a little
confused about how like how the business
model of a battle works well you kind of
got to think of it in a similar vein to
boxing or MMA so you guys have a
pay-per-view site we have a pay-per-view
site we work in conjunction with a
company called rap grid that does
paperwork but all you got to do is go to
our website gtxbattles.com and you can
there's links to the paper people can
can watch it from wherever yeah yeah
yeah yeah but um the as far as the
business model goes things such as
pay-per-view and you know ticket sales
and all that that's kind of just feeding
the event and making sure that we're
able to sustain ourselves what we do it
covers the cost right we partner with
any brand that wants sponsors we sell
eyeballs yeah you know so you get
millions of people in a concentrated
demographic any of you companies want
some eyeballs we got them yeah I just
saw uh so what was the battle that just
happened that enes and Cassidy Bratt
yeah that was the you were there I was
there yeah it goes and yeah um daylight
versus uh king bow and who do you think
is the goat
sitting on the couch over there sitting
on the damn couch
um scrolling Reddit
you know okay if it's disaster is it who
else who's it like who's in that like
four or five rest in peace yeah R.I.P
the patch day he definitely yeah yeah
patch day one thousand percent um he
just passed away last year right he did
he did yeah sad situation yeah
and the whole kotd family
um I'll say this the West Coast the West
Coast Mount Rushmore
there is there's disaster there's Gucci
Gotti rum nitty Denny Myers daylight
daylight okay there's a five-man you
know that's the crew
I'll put thesaurus and immaculate yeah
passwords like there's very strong top
eight on the west coast
um now B dot probably I'll throw up
there too there's there's now as far as
the overall landscape of the culture you
got disaster you got
Loaded Lux you got murder mooc Hollow
the Don you got conceited you got
Arsenal and you got um you know those
same names thesaurus um
ended up making the best music because
that's the one thing about battle
rappers is we always say because I
always enjoyed Sue's music I was going
to say surf it makes my favorite music
in battle rap brochure but you gotta
like the thing is this
every single rapper has battled at some
point right Eminem was a battle rapper
you know what I mean true Meek Mill I
mean there's a lot of so everybody yeah
yeah everyone's battled at some point
whether it's in the cafeteria whether it
was on camera and ask the question right
right but from like the battle rap scene
I would say that um yeser definitely has
the strongest catalog dude because I
remember seeing Supernatural when I was
a little kid I think he opened up like
one of dilate his tours it just blew my
[__] mind three words but I've never
seen that before right where he was like
taking people's ideas and [__] right
spinning around and come back as exhibit
or Bust the Rhymes or whatever right and
uh
and his music wasn't great well that's
the thing like yeah like he and it hurt
my heart because I was like this is the
greatest rap I've ever seen in my life
it's not a mutually exclusive skill set
true you know and even like a lot of the
guys that are just great bar Smiths you
know true true dudes that well you'll
have on your podcast that'll kill it are
you really slapping all their music
probably not you know or I grew up you
know what's crazy I got to the point
where when I was a kid I was like a
hip-hop snob for a little bit where if
it wasn't like super over lyrical I
would like look down on it that's like a
commercial [__] right right we all
went through that phase but now I'm like
I just want to enjoy the music man right
and then there's there's people that are
able to blend all that kind of together
and do it all together like Kendrick or
like you know Kendrick J Cole push a
team and that's why they're the game
like yeah and and even like at the end
of the day really lyricism like
songwriting and lyricism are true
different things people think that just
because you can put bars together means
you know how to craft a record it's a
whole bunch of different nuances you
know yeah for sure and and then there's
the guys like black dot who are just
black thoughts apex predator MCS that
can just do everything he's a Jedi yeah
yeah who just you know run the entire
game into the game but he can do
anything to to revert back to a previous
question you asked um what would I do
differently
I definitely would not let
the opinions of other people's dictate
my emotions it's something that I've
known because I've been on the internet
for years right I mean like I've been
had an active presence I mean the battle
rap scene kind of blew up because of
message boards and yes one thousand
percent you know what I mean and I was
from on the ground floor of that since
2005 in some capacity I've been in the
public eye right however I think that
this point in my life that I was in
towards the end of last year in the
beginning of this year was a very
transitional time in my life and I was
very um vulnerable and probably
shouldn't have been introduced to an
audience this big I probably wasn't
mentally prepared so make sure that my
mental that my mental health is in a
good place and not allow the opinions of
others to dictate my emotions you know
or criticism or praise hey we got to
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to Odd Socks
little Godfather sock right there
craziest licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws pop these boys open
check them out
oh yeah oh yeah a little Chun Lee versus
Blanco
what
amazing
do you like you who so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet I promise
you you gotta go to autotoxofficial.com
right now and use the promo code bootleg
save 20 off your entire order alright so
go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Jardin the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Harding Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you gotta
stop off you gotta go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardeen go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview this is ever find out who this
ghost Reddit guy is Ghost Reddit guy the
guy on what's the Reddit guy you were
supposed to be talking to is it going oh
oh oh um then you're guilty guilty not
ghosts ghosts I do not know who guilty
is to this day Jesus
now yeah and that was in a Discord
server oh see all this [__] is bro
[__]
yeah yeah I always thought Discord I was
on Discord once and it was because I'm a
part of the I talked about this I was on
there's like this flip group where you
they like tell you what to buy and what
you could flip it for right right it was
I had to download Discord and I then I
guess it's for gaming and [__] I guess
it's all different kinds of [__] yeah
yeah discord's good it's um you build a
community very valuable tool like is
there a bootleg Kev Reddit Community or
want that [__]
I feel you don't make one
we're good yeah
buddy I learned I learned a lot though
and I'm grateful for it and you know
have you talked to Adam since
I have not spoken to Adam since the the
morning after
that all went down because I was kind of
like I wasn't even really 100 sure if
you got fired yeah even though I was
like it was still yeah but it was like
you just went off what you saw on that
stream it could be like open-ended it
was it was done out it was done out of
passion like let me see if there's any
reasoning with this guy right in the
morning sometimes people feel a little
bit different you know I sent him a text
um he was just kind of like hey you know
that's it but he what he did say was I'm
not gonna be bad mouthing you or
slandering you any more and I was like
okay cool neither will I then proceeded
to call me a snake multiple times
um on several different podcasts and um
talk down on me so it's kind of like you
know I don't have any hate in my heart
towards him but it's I'm a little
confused by that what about Josh
uh Josh and I have texted on
about business a couple times but like I
need my last paycheck that's kind of
like but that's essentially like the end
of you know and I'm cool Josh I have no
problem with ultimately and um so at the
end of the days you know we we all
straight I still talk to A.D I still
talk to t-rail house phone everybody
um they'll be appearing on my pod and
occasionally I might make some
appearances over there okay have you I
know you've just talked to smack this
morning I know you've been doing your
um I saw
who's the white guy you're on camera
with
on um you're it's like it's a YouTube
channel what's that YouTube channel I'll
ruin your day yeah yeah okay so how like
have you already started your your
actual I have my own individual Channel
That's lush world yeah no so lush world
is actually because here's the thing
that channel that ruined your day
channel is something that I've been
active in actively a part of building
since like 2015. so you already were a
part of that channel yeah yeah okay you
know and helped build a lot of the subs
up right and then when I you know had a
discussion with him is this is going to
be my home on YouTube for curating
content since there's already an
audience built in business-wise him and
I have an understanding and um so I
consider that channel as much mine as
anybody else's okay so then that's where
the lush world stuff's going yeah Lush
rolls over there there's the GTX channel
for battles and there's I have my own
channel for music so yeah are you still
gonna make music I'm I'm always gonna
make music that's like a passion thing
that's just a part of who I am you know
what I mean like I got my distribution
deal with the my label with John Urbano
and Marissa Urbano called um snow cone
records which is uh we we under Sony
Orchard so like you know but it's not
paying the bills but occasionally I'll
get a placement and it'll pop up like I
just got a placement in the show like
you would do it for free so I would
always do it I'll do it for free but I
recently got a placement in a a film
called sick which is on the peacock
Network so you know get a little bag
here and there and when you got your
teeth done yeah
did you do it here did you go to a
different country I did it here oh you
did yeah yeah yeah yeah and these are
actually Temporaries that are going to
be for people who don't know because are
you are you doing the implants yeah
these These are so right now is a bridge
I have a bridge on top and a bridge on
the bottom it's not like Dentures I
can't tell you you're going to get like
full implants right yeah yeah and so
you're not even getting veneers no no no
no no no I have real boys yeah yeah I
have no teeth left on the top or the
bottom in between my canines they
cemented a bridge in so temporary that's
there and um I'll just tell you you're
gonna be out for a while I'll tell you
this little bootleg Kev the [__]
quotient is through the roof good for
you man knocking them down there I'm
glad to hear it I'm knocking them down
where are you finding them the Reddit
they finding me they finding me it's
crazy like I I don't know I was about to
say Jesus Christ we gotta get this
Velcro
you got to get it cemented like my damn
teeth for sure I was gonna say I always
uh what what a note are no jumper
groupies or or battle rap groupies are
they like
what kind of T because I always say the
ugliest groupies in the world are
Juggalos yeah yeah like icps groupies
God bless them just talk about [__] it's
speaking of meth Jesus Christ yeah I'm
not trying to have an orgy at the
Gathering no disrespect to the my
Juggalos you feel yeah shout outs I love
y'all
whoop whoop have you been to the
Gathering I have not I would love to go
to the Gathering I hear there's a drug
tent yeah or no there's a drug bridge I
believe it and then there's like a TP
where there's just a [__] in there you
gang the orgy the orgy 10. what's that
smell like
welfare
Bumblebee tuna child molestation yeah
like a kind of a baby of all that yeah
27 year old chicken there got [__] by
her uncle and her brother at once and
now she's getting [__] by now she's
got an uncle and Ratchet a man tattooed
on her neck right but I would say
there's there's [__] second grade
teachers in this world right now with
Hatchet Man statute on their body you
know that's actually considered a gang
in very yeah and there's like in certain
States like Utah
foreigners but they're in Utah in Utah
there was some Juggalo wound up killing
a Sereno oh and now there's a [__]
green light on the jungle in the Utah
Penitentiary system for anybody with the
hatchet man Jack
so I've been told so the South cider's
got beef with the Juggalos in Utah yes
and I don't know if that's still a thing
but this was yeah that's interesting
yeah what are the Mormons and you can
uh they're Juggalo Mormons or South side
Mormons I don't know but and just to
make it clear this is not something that
I'm bringing to the internet this is
something that's already known if you
you know tap into different places Utah
have you have you ever done a battle on
YouTube I've been to Salt Lake yeah it's
cool it's fun out there is it it is but
as far as groupies I'll tell you this no
jumper groupies are levels beyond the
battle rap group yeah yeah they are yeah
I gotta be honest can you imagine the
kind of chick that just is like every
battle she's there just by yourself
there's like some cute ones though I'm
not gonna lie like we you know like
there's some cute battle rap chicks but
it's definitely like the the [__]
that are the [__] that are in
into no jumper a lot of them were
aspiring only fans models you know what
I mean like did you ever get any porn
chick [__] over there oh yeah yeah oh
yeah just just being over there oh yeah
absolutely nice yeah anybody would talk
about nothing I can no you know what I
don't wanna do you ever take on the
Asian chick with the ass if look here's
no I did not but here's the thing if I
wind up Kazumi yeah yeah you never
[__] zoomy look no but like if I did
I wouldn't say because here's the thing
right that makes me look super lame I'm
not gonna fair not gonna speak on my
dick and then yeah but other [__]
that might be interested in throwing me
some [__] they might judge you based on
their body oh this dude got a big mouth
accumulative body count too the body
counts one thing but like he's he's
gonna put me on blast
I will never put you on blast baby girl
so you're single I'm single currently
good for you man yeah yeah well listen
man I was heartbroken last year you feel
me I got a respect was that your fiance
that was my which one because you said
your fiancee was that who broke your
heart uh well I kind of it was my fault
yeah yeah please pause
um so so you were supposed to get
married yes didn't work out didn't work
out who knows what the future holds yeah
but yeah that's what's up man we'll look
I'm glad you're sober appreciate it stay
sober and know it's a tough journey man
absolutely you go to meetings every week
I do I do several times a week she get
the coins and all that yup got my three
year coin about a month in the house my
sobriety birthday is February 3rd wow
well congrats man stay sober buddy got
you and keep uh this is one thing I'll
tell you man is I know it's very easy
and we already talked about this a bit
earlier
don't pay attention to the comments and
don't pay attention to what anybody else
is doing because I'm sure it's easy to
look over and be like oh [__] this is
happening over here this is how just
worry about building your own [__] Brick
by Brick don't compare Dixon to gangbang
for sure you feel me but with that being
said
with that being said Kev um it's been
it's cool to actually chop it up it's
usually get to know you you feel me yes
sir you might have more in common than
uh I initially even thought we're both
old white dudes who like rap music yeah
you feel me how old are you I'm 41. okay
I'm 36. so we're you know we're yeah
yeah yeah well you know yeah we
definitely are both just old dusty
hip-hop you feel me spinning Dusty
pieces of wax you know the Vibes come on
appreciate your brother man yeah you as
well sir boom